[Music]
would you want to get weird with
i don't know
i don't have any any ideas oh fat oh vin
diesel
yeah yeah what's the vin diesel thing
vin diesel absolutely going
through it in prep for his vin diesel
absolutely going through it in prep for
this movie which is fast x you gotta
punch in on that yeah [ __ ] me man so
this is
someone leaving a comment on his
post about fastax i know my opinion
doesn't matter but i think many of us
would like a classic film for
the finale the first was a classic i
followed your work since i was a boy i
used to pretend to be riddick i used to
perform your dinner scene in xxx a
classic film you also
are a nerd
like the first would
complete the fast and furious i'm sure
it will entertain many but i want to see
the vin from the end of multi-facial
talking about his dad that's the same
vin as dom talking about his dad with
brian by the charger keep being you man
you bring nothing but love and it shows
you got this piece your seven-year-old
fan now 26 dude you're 26. you shouldn't
like vin diesel this much he still
writes like a seven-year-old oh here we
go van i'm jet-lagged
and a bit tired this is him replying to
this but your opinion does matter
it is why i make these movies
when i think
oh the script isn't ready i should do
what other hollywood a-listers do and
walk
i think of you
i think of millions of people who wait
for the fast films like a holiday
through the highs and lows moments of
disappointment to the moments of
confirmation that we always represented
your favorite franchise in dare i say
your family mark zuckerberg himself has
attributed
the social media revolution to my
posting of heart and love back in 2009.
what
the outfit the alpha angel was turning a
year old fast four was released i just
started my facebook account an app
recommended to me by my sister who
graduated harvard grad school and who
happens to be one of the most important
producers to the fast franchise
primarily to be able to include you all
into the process of manifesting this
mythology at the time barack obama was
the only person on social media with
more than a million fans
and because of you we quickly passed him
making our page the leading page
facebook at the time would go to
countries to sign up to their app
promising to be a tool to unite family
and when they said we already have skype
to talk to family facebook would say you
can be friends with vin diesel
what the [ __ ] and they joined the social
media era you also remember when i asked
my incredible fans who wanted to they
wanted me to work with back in 2010 they
said the rock he ended up becoming hobbs
who was initially written for tommy lee
jones to this day hobbs is without
question his best role i'm forever
grateful to him for delivering such a
great character the same was true of
jason statham who also continues to sign
in our saga shine excuse me both are a
product of fan generated casting first
of all him shading the rock at the end
is so [ __ ] petty he's such a such a
backhanded thing so petty dude this is
the next part you got to keep going oh
my god i'm sorry man yes your opinion
has always mattered
when the f10 script came in it excluded
mia toretto because that [ __ ] was ugly
wow
someone who i attributed the brotherhood
of dom and brian to i was so
disappointed that i couldn't see how i
could continue after all i wasn't going
to make another fast unless brian was
back and for
i don't need to remind you of the
petitions you sent to the studio for
letty's return at the end of fast five
oh my god side note you will never
believe who corrected the very important
role of mia my daughter the alpha angel
talked about like a superhero
who told the director very plainly and
honestly no mia no fast 10. ha ha the
irony is that the day she was born i was
filming with jordana and pablo and it
was jordana who i first told what the
[ __ ] is he talking profound right no one
gives a [ __ ] about fast like i know dude
he's the only one that cares this one is
so crazy dude
i can't do any more i'll
i can't okay well like
it just goes on and on and on
like do you think even though do you
think even the producers of this movie
are like who the [ __ ] are half those
people that you just talked about
the producers like dude it's not that
serious it's a [ __ ] race car movie
that makes a lot of money yeah bro
that's all it is no i think all he's
trying to say is you do matter
and then he's talking about himself yeah
yeah
yeah yeah you matter but i'm at her a
little bit more bro
yo vin
is there going to be
a mitsubishi lancer in fast10
back when i invented facebook
[Laughter]
yo dude is there going to be a
supercharged um
dodge challenger in this one that'd be
really cool
though you know it's crazy when my
daughter was born
was filming with pablo i was filming
with jordana brewster and she was like
then you're popping out of that shirt
and i said i know
thanks
all love always check out my new song
[Laughter]
can we close it out with his song
feel like i do feel like i do yeah
classic man how many how many views we
got on this [ __ ]
1.6 million let's go vin
face look at that face just kind of
playful laid back like having a good
time in the sun you know
wait wait for it
driving down the i5 yeah now wait ready
straight forward it's coming
ready wait
[Music]
he's coming
okay sorry it's coming it's coming
it's coming
wait no i think it's here i think it's
here
we fell in love at coachella
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah thank you all for tuning in to a
riveting bonus episode
not that bad this song
it's not that bad
for vin diesel
for vin [ __ ] diesel yeah to put out
like a tropical house song with him
singing it's not that bad
yeah it's kind of the same feeling as
the watching the batman yeah exactly
it's just
pretty mid